join clearly you're a superstar athlete
but you are a luxury lifestyle brand
like here we are I'm wearing your new
Hublot watch this is a $19,000 watch how
do you go from being his kid who plays
basketball to a - luxury icon you say it
like that it sounds like I'm important I
have no idea you know just being a kid
and just having a dream of playing
basketball and basketball it took me to
other places and it's introduced me to
other things in life and and my passion
is the game of basketball 100% but also
have other passions as well and I have
an opportunity to dip and dab in those
passions for me it was like I want more
creative input you know in everything
that I'm doing and I've been able to
team up with the right brands that it
has allowed me to be able to do this so
when it comes to the watches I want to
go more luxury so let's sit down and
talk about what that what that band
looks like let's guess I said on talking
about what the face of is gonna look
like and how I wanted my signature of my
logo place and there's all these little
things so it's just like a cool process
when you talk about the decisions you've
made in terms of style many athletes
spend a lot of time in China because
it's a big market but your shoes for
example to not have a classic shoe deal
like we see so many other basketball
players do why make a Chinese
partnership well for me you know I had
Nike John Ball converse when I was with
converse and then I went to Jordan I was
with that family for nine years and it
was an amazing relationship and I was at
a point in my life when I was I was
turning 30 and I was like you know what
I want to do something leaves a legacy
how can I build my own legacy for my
kids and for me it was like you know
what I want to grow Kevin Durant's shoe
deal that's a lot of money that's a
legacy legacy Dead Money that's a legacy
of 39:30
yeah it's a different kind of legacy so
like at 30 how do I build now how do I
start and build this legacy and for me
it was moreso of just looking at the
bigger picture of my brain wasn't about
the shoe deal it wasn't about the actual
contract it was about what I can build
you know with my brain growing globally
and how they opens up so many doors and
window
for me what is it about the style of
basketball when I see you after a game
or other players you are turning it out
in baseball that is certainly not the
place in hockey basketball players star
basketball players they don't bring the
heat just on the court for a press
conference you are delivering what is it
about this game it's a competitive
nature of you know so when when David
Stern implemented the dress code and all
years ago it became now just the dress
code heard around the world
it became a competitive thing for guys
you know we suggest where everybody said
we're the same thing when I first got in
the lead then it became that competitive
like I see what these guys wearing let
me step my game up and did anywhere from
there - I'm gonna get a stylist in
anyway from that you know so it's just
being competitive and then at the same
time we in the right space in the right
time for me and fashion it just so
happened that we met up at the same time
and now we're respected and we're
accepting into the fashion world which
athletes haven't really been because we
looked at as being lanky and too long
and King no style no Flair and we've
been able to now you know kind of open
those doors what do you want to do in
your next chapter how long do you want
to be playing for Miami um I don't know
as long as my body allows me to play the
game the way that I want to play it and
you know each year is different you know
every year is different it is crazy
because at 33 going to 34 for a better
idea that 30 and 31 why my body is just
I'm not hurting as much you know treat
your body different not very different
how I'll spend more time on my body than
I do on my game when I was younger I
spend more time on my games I did on my
body
what does Kobe Bryant's retirement mean
to you it makes you a little scary
because you know you the next heir up
you know like Kobe's the as he said in
his press comment is that ripple of G
and guys like myself Brian and a 2003
class we - oh jeez Oh Leigh so weird all
the guys you know it's like oh we're the
next ones up you know after the Kobe's
and the Tim Duncan's and the dirts
you know retire so it's kind of scary
from that point but from a sense of a
guy's career someone I admired someone
who was a role model to me as a player
someone I could call a friend his
careers
amazing what do you want to do next I
mean style is so important to you you
want to just take that in a bigger way
in terms of your lifestyle branding I
want to be a Renaissance man I want to
do it all so everything I do at this
point you know it's not about not owning
I don't want to be a part of it and I've
made it very clear that you know when it
comes to the game of basketball one day
don't know when that day is but one day
I would love to have that ownership for
sure at the end of last season you
didn't go on vacation you didn't take a
break you went and enrolled in a class
at Harvard Business School why I want to
be educated in the fields that I want to
go in so for me to be able to go and
talk about business and in marketing and
and you know in all these things it was
it was great for me to go in and be in a
room full of people from different walks
of life different companies that has
probably the same amount of money or
more than I have and to be able to pick
their brains to be able to give them a
perspective from an athlete standpoint
as the talent now but also to hear from
another side too as well of how they
think about equity how they think about
talent how they think about marketing
and all these different things so I just
wanted to kind of stimulate my brain on
the other side and how other people
think why do so many athletes end up
broke getting take advantage of going
from being stars who makes so much money
to losing it all why does that happen
well one of the toughest things is is
you know when guys coming to the NBA
most guys are similar in this sense they
come from broken broken backgrounds we
come from broken backgrounds you're not
used to handling money you know you
don't have nobody in your family has
taught you have sat down and taught you
how to really value and handle money now
you say how can a guy lose millions of
dollars when you come in from you come
from nothing and you you're thrown into
a lot what are you going to do you're
going to enjoy that a lot you're going
to spend it if you don't have no one to
grab you or grab ahold of you and and
help you learn about your money learn
how to invest your money learn how to
save your money it goes fast it's a fast
lifestyle